So, some two years ago I was having the
very first coaching lesson with a
student of mine, who had been trying to
learn Spanish but to no avail, and it
turned out that he had been, you know,
learning the language for a few months
and I asked him: "what are you doing
to learn Spanish?",  and it turns out that
he was actually listening to the radio
and listening massively in order to
understand, in the hope that he would
understand everything with time.
And of course listening comprehension
like all good things takes time, it takes
exposure, but you have to learn how to do it. You might be in the same situation
right now maybe you're learning a
language and you're wondering why you
still don't understand the language, why
is it so difficult, why are you
struggling, and in this very same video
I'm going to give you some fundamental
tips on how to make your listening comprehension fantastic in a relatively short amount of time.
So in this video I'm going to give you the
fundamental rules of thumb or tips in
order to understand any language quickly
and effectively and we're going to have
a very cool extra tip at the end,
so please, stay tuned. The fundamental
rule of thumb in order to understand the
language better and better is to get
exposed to comprehensible input, that is,
input that you can understand and when
you are a beginner when you first start
learning a language, make sure that you
always always listen and read at the
same time because if you can read and
listen at the same time, you will be able
to actually SEE the words that are being
spoken and this allows you to build
comprehensible input that will help you
in the intermediate stage when you can
venture into the unknown ground of pure
listening. But you have to remember that
the listening comprehension process as
well as the language learning process is
not linear but it's progressive, so
always make sure no matter what stage
you're in that you expose yourself to
comprehensible input, the input that you
can' understand at least to 70 or 80
percent.
How many times have you found yourself sitting in a class and not caring at all about when you were
listening to? This is common especially and when
to language learning at school at
university because people are not
interested, they're in a passive state of
mind, and one of the reasons is because
they're not interested in what they're
listening to. They they don't care, they
didn't choose the material, they didn't
choose the audio or the text. So as an
independent language learner, YOU have
the possibility of listening to whatever
you like. Make sure that what you listen
to is something you find interesting
because if it is interesting for you, your
levels of dopamine in your brain
will literally skyrocket and you will
absorb the content much better.
Have you ever found yourself interacting with native speakers in a language you still
didn't know well and you're trying to
understand every single word they try
that they were saying to you? Well I
think that a better technique or a
better strategy is to simply focus on
the big picture.
I really like the sentence in English
"missing the forest for the trees" - you
don't want to "miss the forest for the
trees" so even if you don't understand
all the words, focus on the big picture
so focus on the cue words inside the
sentence that would give you the meaning
of the sentence even if you don't
understand all the elements of the
sentence itself, this is really important
so relax you need to understand
everything you just focus on the main
things on the main cues, and focus on the
big picture.
Every uttered sentence in any language is
a complex combination of sounds.
In order to make your life easier  to
understand, absorb and replicate these
phonetic pattern, you might want to make
your life easier and do things
step-by-step. One very very easy
strategy in order to tackle this problem
is very simple: you just slow the audio
down. So take the audio track or the
audio tracks that you have, play them at
normal speed and then play them a little
bit more slowly. In order to do this you
have many possibilities nowadays, for
example you can use free software
programs that you can download from
the internet like AuDIria (or AudiRIa)
but you can also use Google Translate.
You can simply put a sentence inside the
box and play it and the second time it
will be uttered slowlier. So this is very
simple: make sure that you always slow
down the audio, look at the bigger
picture, look at the details, and make it
a habit. Especially at the beginning, this
will make a big difference.
if I say the word "listening" associated with language
learning, probably you think
Ok, listening to a podcast or listening and
watching a movie or listening to music
in a foreign language. That is true, but
there are so many other activities you
can engage in when it comes to listening,
and it's not only WHAT you do but HOW
you do it and WHERE you put your
attention. You can for example
listen to a podcast just for the sake of
listening to it while you are running some
errands but you can also listen to a
podcast focusing on the pronunciation
and intonation of the language that you
you're listening to or you can even take
notes that is you're listening to a
podcast in a foreign language for the
sake of grabbing and absorbing
information so what you do and how you
do it counts and you have to make it
varied. The more varied activities the better.
"Good things take time" - I always say
it out loud to myself when things get frustrating
and they do get frustrating when for example I don't understand the
language still, when I would like to talk
to someone and I still just understand
the gist of it, when I don't understand
the radio. So you have to remind yourself
that it takes massive exposure to
understand the language, it takes volume
it takes sampling. These are the most
important nutrients for your brain. So on
the one hand you need massive exposure
on the other hand you have to find the
system to distribute this massive
exposure you have to do it day by day.
That's the best way and how to do that?
Well, just one of the strategy is to
associate your listening activity with
something else for example you just
listen to something that you can
obviously understand and you do it while
you're doing something else
I myself do some work out in the morning
while I listen to Polish podcasts. So
remember to do something every single
day, be consistent, good things take time but
if you do that, you will make it happen.
So here you have it: listening and
understanding the language takes time
but it's not difficult you learn how to
do it and you have to be consistent.
Now if you want to know more just click on the description box below and head over
my blog where you will be able to listen
to the article I put together and you
can even just listen to it so you can do
this while doing something
as I suggested in this very same video.
Now I have one question and one extra
tip for you let's start with a question.
What is the biggest struggle that you
have when it comes to listening
comprehension and what have you done to
overcome it or what do you think you can do to overcome it? So since you've been in
so patient I want to reward you for your
patience and I'm going to give you one
cool extra tip and here it is: When we think about listening, we tend to think that
listening is just a passive activity
just listen to something and the sounds
flow into your ear but you can actually
do something that can completely change
your strategy and your listening
comprehension and that is be ACTIVE. Let
me give you a very simple example when
you listen to something that obviously
you can understand, you can just listen
to it maybe you're running some errands
or you can sit down and take notes when
you take notes you will realize how your
attention changes because your entire
body is listening to that piece of
information. So the next time take a
youtube video, listen to it and take
notes, and you will see how that
influences and improves the way you
understand the piece of content and the
way you absorb it.